Ramona Shelburne the fantastic columnist
in the NBA reporter for ESPN in our
Direct TV 4k NBA report here on the Rich
Eisen show even Ramona good are you guys
I am doing fine what is the story of the
season right now as we are as we are now
post Thanksgiving normally normally that
would just be a couple weeks under our
belt but we're a full month and a half
into the NBA season no yeah I think I
guess I'd go with the Celtics so far
right I mean like that's the team that
like you know overnight they lose Gordon
Hayward and you're like they're gonna
just like everything they had tried to
do this summer just falls apart and not
only have they been great but they're
proud of their probably the best team
league right now I'm at that win streak
and and some of the games that they have
one especially beating goals I didn't
think they're gonna be Golden State I
thought the Warriors would get up for
that right now because there's so much
parody I mean like we you know what we
go around every weekend do our rankings
right we go through in there's there's
so many teams that are sitting there
just a couple games above or below 500
that really the only the only teams that
have kind of separated themselves
they're like Celtics in the Rockets
the Warriors sort of underachieved but I
think that's almost a planned
underachievement
until the Celtics word I guess I'd be my
story and then the Cavs have suddenly
pulled it together they've won seven in
a row and then the news over the weekend
that Derrick Rose is taking some time to
ponder his his professional basketball
playing future what did you make of that
story Ramona yeah sad right and it's
like so so today Tony Parker's coming
back right and I was I was reading his
quotes you know San Antonio express-news
and said you know it's just this love of
the game and and it you know I'm I
wanted to go out you know feeling good
this is what pushed me back because like
me Tony Parker got hurt people thought
that might be it for him like that
injury was really severe and nine months
January February he's already back he's
back before Kauai even and you could see
the the passion he still has for the
game and then you see Derrick Rose and
compare the types of players they were
like Tony was never there like athletic
monster that Derrick was but he was he
was quick and he had a game that was
built on speed
decision and look at how he's changed
his game and his his whole being to
evolve as a player right as a person
dealt with injury after injury and and
then you look at Derek where I don't
think he's ever really been the same
without his athleticism and some people
are able to do that they have like the
coping skills and the ability to to
change who they are fundamentally the
player as their body begins to fail them
and their just doesn't and it's it's I
understand why he's frustrated I mean
year after year after year in Chicago or
he's like the guy who's supposed to
return them to glory like Michael Jordan
hometown and so for him to now you know
have go to Cleveland on a minimum deal
great and not be able to play from a
stupid ankle injury or he lands on Greg
Monroe's foot I mean it's it's it's if
this is I don't think this is the end I
do think he comes back but I think he
just doesn't really know who he is when
he can't be that guy that's what a
marvel well I mean we've seen it before
in so many other sports to where you
have to recalibrate yourself and remake
yourself and certainly you know he's on
a team when Isaiah Thomas returns that
has championship aspirations maybe the
ring can be the thing that gets him gets
him back here Ramona Shelburne here on
the Rich Eisen show Philadelphia is so
much fun to watch I mean where is Sam
hinkie today is he just underground or
where is he the guy who came the process
in trusting him hanging out in my old
hood man he's up at Stanford University
hanging out with the Nerds in Silicon
Valley or a like that that's his crew
and I think he's just kind of sitting
back and letting everybody talk because
like you don't need to say anything
right you know he did he didn't it's
paying off and it's working and this is
gonna be I think the sixers like okay
you you as we start off and what's the
story right now the Sixers are what's
next okay cuz like that's the team you
when you watch those guys play and they
came through LA I guess a couple weeks
ago and they beat the Lakers and the
Clippers and it was like the way they
beat them every game ambulant 446 and 15
and 7 and 7 I mean no one's ever done
that and like you know if you watch them
play and you went oh my god like this
guy I've never seen this
skill set like this before in one player
he he's a dominant as Shaquille O'Neal
has been on the block at times okay and
but he can make free throws he can hit
threes
he's got the dream shake he's got a Euro
step like you've never you don't see
these things and a guy that seven foot
two and then there's Ben Simmons who
plays like LeBron but like is this good
and can't even shoot like he doesn't
know what hand he shoots with inside he
shoots with his right hand and outside
he shoots this weird shot with his left
hand and it I mean like he's this good
putting up like magic Johnson type
rookie stats and he doesn't even shoot
like think how good these guys operate
and the number one pick in the draft
mark helpful sooo this like
pick-and-roll monster he can you know
get his shoulder right and his head back
together and and how to shoot like we
haven't even seen them yet and like I
know they're they're playing the Cavs
tonight right I mean this is one of
those ones where I can't wait for the
trash talk because that's what embiid
lives for these things right but this is
I mean if you're if you're LeBron and
you're looking at that team and I know
we talked a lot about LaGrant Lakers and
the Cavs and what's its future gonna be
shoot look at Philly I mean that's the
team with the guy that's the team with
the young stars better closest to
winning Ramona she'll burn in the
DirecTV 4k NBA report here while we're
on the subject of playing in Los Angeles
putting up Magic Johnson rookie type
stats and having a shot that you don't
know what it is you see where I'm going
with it
you know if Lavar ball and Donald Trump
weren't going at each other I think
lavars shot at Luke Walton that we were
all no one was going to come at some
point the fact that he finally took it I
think would have been far more a piece
of catnip for the national media
what has Magic Johnson said to levar
after all that or did they just say
that's just levar being levar and let's
all ignore it what is the strategy here
yeah they don't want telev are with you
he's grown man and they knew what they
were signing up for and sort of anti
Laker to sort of can't doubt on anything
that creates news right
Hollywood female care right they they
think it's fun but I what they do is
they they do things like he shits in the
family area you know there's a certain
area that you're not supposed to talk to
people well you know and no go you can't
you can't do any interviews over there
like oh that's where the bar is right I
mean they do little things like that but
but look he's a grown man I mean they're
watching it and they're there monitoring
it you know I know people saw that was a
it came across the shot at Luke Walton I
don't I don't think it was because I
just gotta have a different take on the
bar and his whole relationship with
Lanza like I sort of felt like that was
levar saying you need to kick lonzo's
butt a little bit I thought that was him
saying giving Luke was some license to
just say get in there and yell at him
get in there and push him because I'm
giving you license and not that was
needed that okay looks great coach but
he you know he doesn't need daddy's
permission to do that but I think maybe
that's the the guy who's trained Blondo
his entire life and when I say trained I
you use that word specifically not just
coach he trained him so like you know
think of it think of like a trainer you
know lawns of the guy who you know the
dad says be here at nine o'clock we're
gonna run Hills he shows up at nine
o'clock and they run hills he doesn't
call it that and say hey I want to get
there at seven o'clock and shoot shoot
baskets he waits for someone to tell him
what to do and so you have to understand
that dynamic and how lonzo's sort of
always been coached tonight I think it
was more advice I think it was more him
saying like look when he's acting like
this when he's in his head a little bit
just go in there and kick his butt a
little bit but you know clearly if
there's anybody who understands what
it's like to have a dad who they say too
much impact might be might be Ramona
like an you know yeah not worried about
I think teammates if he starts
criticizing Clinton then we had a
different story but if you just saying
kick my son in the butt a little bit I
don't think I love it Ramona always
enjoyed chatting let's chat again soon
you got that Ramona she'll burn the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience
you